you can also join the discussion on the
david pakman show subreddit that's at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t
nearly 34 000 of our viewers and
listeners are now subscribed there
spotted a few interesting posts this
morning that i wanted to talk about one
user asks
does david think the word karen should
be bannable in the past he said this is
a racially charged word
no i don't think i mean listen bannable
by who we don't ban people for using it
what i've said before is
i
make every effort not to use
any words
that are pejoratives
grouping people by race and while
i don't know if it's explicit or not
karen is essentially a pejorative about
entitled white women
and so i see no reason to use the term
it's conceivable that it may have gotten
into a youtube title or two a while ago
uh but i've stopped using it and as an
editorial thing i i i don't think it's
uh particularly useful
the question about bands i think is
related to recently uh there was this
big dust up on twitch where two
streamers uh that are kind of in our
universe hassan [ __ ] and ian vosh
were banned for using the word i mean
i guess i have to be careful it's a word
you know saltines would be in this
category
um
[Music]
cheez-its would be in this category it's
a pejorative for white people
they were banned and a bunch of people
on the left kind of came out defending
it saying the word isn't really racially
charged um i see it as racially charged
and so my take was
again i don't think it's really a word
progressives should use it's a it's a
pejorative about white people if you
think about the word it doesn't apply
you don't think about asians when the
word is said you don't think about
native americans it's about white people
i avoid pejoratives that group people by
race now you know
twitch bans in terms of service i don't
know i think it's all kind of dumb but
the point is if you're banned for using
the n-word it's not shocking that you
would be banned for using a pejorative
about white people even if they don't
have the same historical weight which
they don't uh and i admit so that's my
view about karen that's my view about
the c word the n-word etc um another
post that i spotted biden official warns
covet explosion imminent yeah so listen
there's there's bad news and then
there's maybe okay news when it comes to
covid i've not been covering the
day-to-day of the omicron variant
because information is changing so
quickly if we look at the uk right now
they are seeing record cases it's wild
what's going on in the uk that being
said the uk is doing a lot of testing
and the data we have right now
still points to
omicron being more mild is it as mild as
the flu which is about a fifth as deadly
as the original covet strains we don't
know should people still get vaccinated
and boosted yes
absolutely
should the immunocompromised and others
take serious precautions yes
but
the potentially less bad thing is that
at the individual level
omicron may be milder and it continues
to to point that way the problem is you
have to remember
as an individual if omicron is more mild
if you get it you're less likely to be
seriously ill
at the population level
if it's significantly more contagious
even though any one person's odds are
getting really sick or lower it'll still
fill up the hospitals and if you think
about burden of disease if it's half as
deadly but three times as contagious if
i get it it's less likely for me that it
will be serious but it's still going to
lead to way more people
getting very very sick so you know i'm
still waiting for something more
definitive but that's the way it looks
so far
last post i spotted what is up with the
weird lighting in david's studio
is it just me or is it dimmer seems if
he's trying to switch things up now what
what's going on is i've been on the road
and our new mechanism you know it's
the audience is very fickle and
emotional and sometimes when it's clear
that i'm on the road and i have a
different background people get very mad
i mean it's it's crazy sometimes people
get mad that i'm doing something
sometimes people get mad that i'm not in
the studio so for a while now when i'm
on the road i've been using a green
screen and it replicates the home studio
now some people notice i'm in a
different place because my mic is
different or the lighting's a little
different or whatever
this time around the equipment i chose
is not quite as good
so things are a little bit degraded i've
gone weeks in the past on the road and
people haven't noticed when i've had
other equipment with me this time it's
noticeable we're going to try to do
better next time
you can join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit